he is the only man in the businesses
represented nearly 30 first-round draft
picks over the last three years and it
was a 10th round pick in the 1974 draft
himself good to have Tom Condon of
Creative Artists Agency right here and
the Rich Eisen show studio how are you
Tom
I'm doing great rich thank you for
having me what's the first deal you did
your career the first one the first one
was actually while I was still playing
and it was art still who was my locker
mate in New England or at the end in
Kansas City
no firt my actually I was still playing
in Kansas City okay right art still had
been the second pick in the first round
in the draft and he was going on to his
second contract we called him one mil
still because he had signed originally I
think it was a seven-year contract for a
million dollars and at the end of that
deal he said Tommy why don't you
represent me and I said art I'm sitting
next to you in the locker room and he
said all you'll figure it out just do it
are you serious oh yeah absolutely
did did you ever communicate to him that
you wanted to be somebody who would do a
contractor you know at the time I was I
don't remember if I was the president of
the Union but I was certainly on the
executive committee and had been the
player rep and all that dry stuff so he
was used to you know talking to me about
those kinds of things and and I was in I
was still in law school at the time and
and I had a buddy in law school who
wanted to be a sports agent so we did it
together so did you go to Lamar Hunt is
that who you dealt with at the time no
no it would and I didn't do it I just I
wrote everything up gave it to my gave
it to my buddy Tony eggnog
right and and he would read it to Jim
Shaw who was our general manager okay
and then you became the president of the
NFL PA it's obviously in your career
yeah 84 to 86 I did that 2-year stint as
president what were the main issues at
the time when you were there we had just
finished this the 82 strike and so the
82 strike was 57 days longest strike in
the history of professional sports up
until baseball when they won they stayed
out for a year yeah the 94 World Series
getting blown off right uh-huh
but nevertheless we yeah so at the at
the end of the at the end of that time
and the story
I nominated Gene Upshaw as executive
director he was voted in unanimously as
executive director of the NFL Players
Union and subsequently I got nominated
for president and you know won that
election what's your relationship with
the current the current executive
running the Players Association DISA
method yeah I mean we have a warm
relationship and he's very bright guy
and I think he's a very well-meaning and
uh in a really good lawyer
no not to get into it but I mean we
might as well is what's the horizon look
like right now with the Players
Association in the league needing to get
a new collective bargaining agreement
that's about three years away when this
really begins to heat up or is it
heating up right now based on what you
could tell I think they're they're at
least seems to be some engagement now on
some different some different issues but
I would I would think this the players
are always going to have a kind of a
difficult issue and the issue is there's
1800 of them in the 1800 go from the
majority or playing for the minimum and
then you've got another group of players
that are you know at the very top end of
the spectrum and they're making between
twenty and thirty million dollars a year
so you've got guys that you know 500 600
thousand and they're you know taking
care of their families and many of them
extended families that kind of thing in
a in a player like you know Maddie ice
there in Atlanta it's hard to go to him
and say hey we want you to sit out for a
year and miss 30 million dollars as much
as it is the $500,000 player that you're
saying it's hard to see it's hard to sit
out for a year because you don't have
any money and how are you gonna live
it's also hard to turn to somebody of
the natural is what I call him Tom just
to be you know fully aboveboard and he
doesn't he says he likes it I don't
believe it right even though he's he
doesn't live he likes okay I know but
it's tough to go to somebody of Matt
Ryan or anybody doesn't matter how much
money they make of his high character of
which there are
majority in the NFL players of that high
character and say let's walk because we
need to make sure that player discipline
is this way that we like it even though
you know it may not be sitting on their
doorstep at any point in time right Tom
yeah absolutely because the player
discipline issue is is so difficult to
fight for because you're talking about
such a small percentage of the players
that are going to have this as as they
as a potential issue and so the majority
of the guys the vast majority of the
guys are absolutely as good at people as
you could ever meet and so and and as a
matter of fact I've always gone through
the recruiting process thinking about
you know intelligence character and
passion for the game and goes without
saying that they have to be able to play
but nevertheless those guys you know
they'll play forever so yet people like
Antonio Gates and Anquan Boldin and Tony
Gonzalez and all that type of player and
they go on and play for you know 16 17
years Tom Condon agent here on the Rich
Eisen show what is bold and up to these
days Tom well you would still like to
play in would you would yes but you know
he he's got a lovely family and he would
like to play and ideally he'd like to
play someplace close to their home in
South Florida so that he could get back
and forth to see the the children in two
and two watches his son's play play
sports but we just saw an opening
potentially with a due to surgery in
Jacksonville I mean is your phone rung
on that front
well actually my phone just rang and it
was Anquan right before he came on the
show so I've got to call him as soon as
we get off okay so yes still wants to
play despite him saying he you know he
wouldn't he wanted to step back to deal
with social issues primarily he would
like to get back on the football field
and play again he would and in last year
there wasn't you know he signed with
Buffalo right and then withdrew in and
he did because of the issue with his
children and
my understanding of it is that at the
very end his oldest son asked him to
stay home are you hearing from members
of front offices that players are not
gonna be signed or we don't want guys
coming on because they might be socially
active are you hearing any of that Tom
no I haven't heard that at all the yeah
I mean it hasn't come up as an issue
well is that because your players are
not predominantly socially active or I'm
just trying to determine as you know the
issue with Eric Reid and Colin
Kaepernick not having jobs and clearly
you take a look across the landscape and
they're talented enough to get jobs do
you think that there's any there there
based on your conversations you've had
Tom you know I would guess so and it's
interesting because yeah if you're
socially active and and it's going to be
a controversial issue then yes
potentially that's gonna hurt you in the
in the job market as does my players who
are you know 33 years old or so there's
an unbelievable age bias house because
the feel that once you hit 33 your
skills diminish well actually it's
anybody over 30 is in jeopardy but when
you're getting to 33 or 34 they think
not only are you is your speed gonna go
but that you're more susceptible to
injury and this is non quarterbacks
clearly right I mean you've got clients
like Alonso and Brees I mean these are
guys who are getting up there to say the
least I think Drew's what 39 no he is
again Eli's getting up there as well how
much longer do you think at Tom Condon
here on the Rich Eisen show how much
longer you think Eli wants to play well
we've got two years left on the contract
so I I would guess he's gonna at least
play through those two but I would I
would also think that he keeps himself
in tremendous condition he's good at
every part of it I mean whether it's the
diet or the flexibility or the sleep or
the or the actual you know cardio and
strength workouts he he does it all
um and so I I don't doubt that he can
play for out for you know several more
years
how about Brees he says he wants to go
to 45 and I'll tell you his his
preparation is absolutely impeccable I
mean and you know he's not a huge man
right
I mean he's six feet tall and 203 pounds
and and he looks like I earned I mean he
takes his shirt off and he says tall abs
and rippling muscles and and one day as
I said I said drew I said I said you
throw the ball with such velocity and
with such distance I said you know at
your age how do you do it and he said I
throw it with my body I don't throw it
with my arm interesting do you get the
sense that the Saints want him around
till he's in his mid-40s Tom well I
think that the the Saints are just like
everybody else you start to get nervous
when a guy's 40 years old right and
you're thinking about well we've got to
replace him at some point so they've got
to look around
Tom Condon here on the Richardson show
is Sam Bradford do you believe he's
gonna be starting for the Arizona
Cardinals against Washington in a couple
weeks yes I love Sam he was I just
recall when when I was first associated
with him or trying to be associated with
him he had won the Heisman at Oklahoma
he came back his senior year to try to
win the national championship he injured
his throwing shoulder and instead of
sitting out or getting surgery he
decided to try to play again and he went
back in and of course blew his shoulder
and so we had to set his pro day back as
close to the draft as we possibly could
and then it was the finest workout I've
ever seen and so while we're on this
subject as somebody who if you will
calls the action Tom Condon for the
combine and the NFL Network and the
programming that it it brings to the
fans and also to the NFL network's
ratings why do you tell clients to not
throw with the combine when they're
gonna be first overall selection stomm
is that what you're doing well you know
sometimes yeah absolutely
stop doing that Tom come on why what's
the point of that
well you know it's interesting the we
had Josh Allen throw this year yes and
and Sam Darnell did not and and so you
know it was it's one of those things
where I went to the spring I went to the
spring game to see to see Josh to play
yes and and so you can't help but look
at him and think to yourself oh my god
he's 65 240 pounds and he looks athletic
and he's explosive when he runs and and
he moves like an athlete and then the
ball came out of his hand and I'd never
seen anything like it in my life well I
mean that's what we want to see them
throw if there's a competition that we
want to see from these guys right at the
combine right so I guess then let me ask
you this what do you think is the
benefit of not throwing the benefit of
not throwing is that it's it's a fairly
unrealistic kind of a setup from the
standpoint of the quarterbacks gonna
throw two receivers that he doesn't know
that he's never seen before running
routes that they may call it the same
but run it differently at their schools
no I know but have discounts and
evaluators know that Darnell would be
throwing to somebody who he's never
thrown to before and the route was not
run properly and they wouldn't count it
as a great against Darnell I don't count
on them and not counting anything so I
just never want to see my player not
have a good day and so every time that
they're gonna be in front of the NFL
people I expect them to be absolutely
prepared for whatever they're gonna have
happened Tom Condon here on the Rich
Eisen show are we seeing right now more
top-of-the-line players holding out or
having problems getting long-term
contracts because we're seeing running
backs like Bell wide receivers
potentially like Beckham it seems that
everything's going well now these are
not your clients so I say this fully
understanding and Darin Donald who is
within your universe in your office but
not your client and Khalil Macke not
your client guys who are saying I want
to be paid like quarterbacks
or have my salary have a larger
percentage than previous guys towards a
quarterback rate are we seeing more
holdouts because NFL front office's are
not gonna pay guys in that regard Tom
Condon well you know it's interesting
because the ever since 1993 in the
inception of the salary cap the the
money had to funnel to the players that
change the outcome of the game and the
outcome of the game is determined on
third down and so you look at the
players that are making plays on third
down and offensively that you're you
know typically you're a quarterback and
your left offensive tackle and your deep
threat wide receiver and then
defensively it's going to be the player
in the secondary that turns the ball
over in the disruptive defensive lineman
and so we're talking about these
virtually the same five positions have
always held the highest average per year
or franchise tag since 1993 and so
that's that's not going to change but I
think that that may be because of for
instance with Aaron Donald we're not
used to seeing a defensive tackle you
know have that kind of an impact
although what's the defensive tackle in
Philadelphia if my partner represents
him - he said it flex Fletcher Cox or
Bennett or it [ __ ] yeah yeah who also
makes a huge impact but I just remember
watching Aaron Donald at the Senior Bowl
and thinking okay he's unblockable yes I
know but we're also seeing in in the
same way that the catch rule had to be
changed because we're seeing guys like
Dez Bryant take two steps and it's the
span of ten yards whereas we never used
to see that the combine just to bring
that up again real quick guys are
getting bigger stronger faster they're
jumping out of the building so positions
need to change in that regard I mean
levy on bail what he's doing he's
touching the ball and impacting the game
and again I know these are not your
clients but what I'm saying is where is
this all going do you think there will
be a front office that that fully
understanding it's been this way since
93 says it's the
changing the game we saw Gurley get a
nice contract for instance I mean are we
going to see that where is this all
going in your estimation it's
interesting because gorilla and Aaron
Donald are on the same team right yeah
girly the running back who typically the
NFL thinks the running back sir
you know interchange of launched a
dime-a-dozen and they have a short
career length and so that's you know
that's why the the rookie system has
probably been more difficult for the
running back than for any other position
and so so you don't think this is gonna
change at all essentially yeah yeah no I
think you'll have some exceptions but I
don't think you're gonna see in the
overall you know massive changes so what
about guaranteed contracts like the one
we saw Kirk Cousins just son in
Minnesota's yeah it was interesting you
know Kirk Cousins had a three year
guarantee on his contract yes but prior
to that time he had three one-year
contracts correct yeah he made a lot
more money right sure yeah so he's so he
had so totally he was six years going
through that process in three of the
years he knew were guaranteed when he
signed the contract but prior to that he
had to do you know one year at a time
you need that for and he did that for
three years before he got the three-year
contract yes
so the ideally it is that as a for
instance in a in a player like Alex
Smith who's on his now third team yes
and he goes to Washington and does a 71
million dollar guarantee and the 71
million is guaranteed completely by
March of 2019 and the 71 million is is
also paid by the end of the third year
so that means the this structuring the
contract is more important than the
average per year hmm so when you're
finishing up with Alex Smith who I love
okay love even though I believe you told
him not to throw at the combine to
didn't you tell yes he I've got a memory
like an elephant when I'm covering on
come on from the NFL okay
network I love Alex Smith love him we
had him on at the Super Bowl
this year he's doing some some
promotional business I asked him
point-blank do you know what your future
is do you know where you're going and he
said I feel like I should have the
opportunity to go wherever I want to go
later on that day it's announced he's
going to Washington did Alex Smith lie
to me on that day Tom did you lie to me
that oh I don't think so okay no we
didn't know that until the last minute
really later on that night okay well you
tell what our other teams were there
what other teams were there for his
services actually Andy never told me he
just said that he's this he was that he
picked the best team for him I'll tell
you what man he's set up an idol I
really love that guy he's just a great
community guy he's a great guy and he's
he's just you know he's he's a guy that
has just succeeded beyond what a lot of
people have expected despite his number
one overall draft status well yeah he's
had he's had a great career and I mean
just in terms of toughness and stick to
it and I mean he went through the eight
years in San Francisco where I think in
his first six he had six different
offensive coordinators yeah yeah I mean
he's and he's not a liar Alex Smith is
not alone according to Tom Connor in
this agency
say hello to all your clients that I
that I mean my gosh there it's the ton
of them right here man and thanks for
coming on the show pleat can we do this
regularly when you're here in Los
Angeles and your son is now working with
you right now yeah he is we've he's been
let's see he's been with me for the last
six years and he's a young lawyer and so
that's a very enjoyable part of the
practice for me fantastic we'll come
back as as they as the as the season
progresses I've got I could sit here and
talk with you for another hour there's
so many issues that you're obviously on
the front lines about with the NFL so
I'd love to have you back any time
you're up for it thank you Richard same
you Tom Condon of CAA right here on the
Rich Eisen show Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience